a passion for power tools is hardly a
crime but in Russia this repair and
remodeling business is officially
illegal because Yulia and Nadia run it
and they're women in Russia women are
banned from more than 450 jobs they're
considered too dangerous carpentry
plumbing and electrical work are on the
list also legally off-limits for women
at work lifting more than 10 kilos more
than twice an hour Yulia and Nadia are
pushing back against these laws and
against gender stereotypes people only
very rarely react well to our work
especially men
people don't say it's great that you do
that they're usually incredulous or they
just laugh they react negatively look I
think it's in videographer gender roles
are deeply entrenched in Russia and
Russian law enforces that apparently
doing too much heavy lifting at work can
harm a woman's health and also harm her
so-called childbearing function
protecting women and their reproductive
organs from dangerous work is a remnant
from post-war Soviet Russia when the
government wanted to increase the
birthrate but the latest list of banned
professions was passed in 2000 and many
Russians still approve of its spirit
money earning in existence for the
family that's men's work for a long long
time men were hunters and women guarded
the half at home made you go women
probably can't carry railway ties and
men would probably find it hard to knit
or do embroidery so everyone has their
own doctor priori kamusta merits boots
yeah Ostrovsky from the Center for
social and labor rights in Moscow thinks
the list of banned women's professions
is outdated and discriminatory did not
seniority provision as called Cohen
Easter list of professions needs to be
reviewed to see if they're dangerous
nowadays and if the working conditions
are dangerous then they would have just
as negative and effect on men as on
women this law treats women and men
differently legally revenir with
national machine arrangin Julia and
Nadia changing attitudes to gender is as
important as renovating apartments they
make a point of only working for women
and of treating their clients as equals
the client will say that's interesting
that's probably hard we tell her grab
the wrench and don't pull it too tight
and often our clients end up helping
with repairs and of course we don't
charge them unlike when I have worked
with men Nadia and Yulia treat me as an
equal and they actually listen to what I
want instead of sticking to Russian
labor laws Yulia and Nadia hope to
expand their business hire other women
and put such work within the reach of a
new generation